foreign
the birthplace of zombies the cursed
land guarded by Baron samadhai the Loa
or Spirit of death according to
tradition all this and more can be found
in Haiti a Caribbean land populated by
demons capable of taking away the will
of many Haitians well visual politic
viewers this is at least what many
French thought when this place was still
their colony of Santo Domingo or even
the Americans themselves when they
invaded the country in 1916. in fact did
you know that zombies became popular in
the United States during the American
invasion in the early 20th century so
yes that has been the main cultural
influence of this country of course
let's be honest this Macabre
presentation of Haiti and its people
served a very specific purpose the
ability to dominate a territory that had
become the richest colony in the world
and which occupied an absolutely
strategic position in the Caribbean
Haiti could have become one of the
richest countries in Latin America
however Destiny had prepared a very
different path for it one that would
lead it to become the poorest country in
Latin America in the Northern Hemisphere
and one of the poorest on the the entire
planet Beyond Voodoo zombies and Spirits
Haiti today is practically what we would
call a failed state
[Music]
spiral of political instability since
its independence in 1804 in these almost
200 years very few governments have
remained stable in fact certainly the
most stable period of the country was
also the cruelest period we are talking
about the family dictatorship of
Francois duvalier and after his death
that of his son Jean-Claude between them
they held power for almost 30 years and
established one of the most extreme
regimes of Terror and history but that
will be the subject of another video
don't forget to subscribe so you don't
miss it the fact is of course that all
this instability was not fortuitous
after its independence Haiti inheritance
are Brewing social tension based on race
a situation that made violence become a
national Hallmark now however things are
even worse violence has raged out of
control and is rampant large parts of
the country are in the hands of gangs
and famine lurks around the corner that
is why the interim president Ariel onri
is looking for a way to curb gang
violence to do so he is looking to two
of his neighbors the United States and
El Salvador the question is what exactly
has caused Haiti's desolation how
precisely did the country end up in the
hands of gangs and criminal groups how
does the Haitian government hope to
mitigate the violence what capacity does
it even have to do so today we're going
to answer all of these questions but
first let's look at some history
eternally punished throughout history
[Music]
I don't think it will come as a surprise
to anyone if I say that among the
poorest countries in the world we find
places like Burundi Somalia or Sierra
Leone but what happens if we focus
exclusively on the American continent
this is exactly what happens yes many of
you might think that Venezuela and its
bolivaran revolution made it the poorest
country in the Americas however as you
can see Haiti is still ahead you see
things got off to a bad start very early
on after its independence from France
the European power began a harsh
blockade against its former colony and
demanded the payment of 150 million
francs this converted into dollars and
adjusted for inflation would amount to
more than 700 million dollars of course
that was not the worst of it nor was the
merely extractive occupation of
resources that the United States carried
out between 1916 and 1934.
[Music]
thank you
worse was the very dynamics of this
country tensions between the black and
mulatto populations grew ever more
intense power struggles were constant
coup d'etats followed one after another
and presidential assassinations were not
uncommon all washed down of course with
plenty of corruption so you could say
that stability has been conspicuous by
its absence without going any further
jovanel Moyes the president who was
assassinated in 2021 was also implicated
in corruption cases it is something like
the prevailing Norm thousands protest
against corruption in Haiti protesters
are demanding president jovenel Moise
resigned for failing to tackle
corruption months of protests have
engulfed the Western hemisphere's
poorest country yet the most striking
feature of Haiti throughout its 200
years of Independence and particularly
in the last six decades has been
violence take a look at this
in 1958 the Haitian dictator Francois
duvalier created the Tonton makutz a
militia whose objective was to increase
the tyrant's control over the country
and reduce the presence and influence of
the army an army that had been trained
by the United States during its
occupation and was not particularly
loyal to him that is to say the dictator
created a sort of praetorian guard at
his personal service to control the
streets and when his son Jean-Claude
duvalier was finally overthrown and this
militia was disbanded suddenly all kinds
of gangs militias and paramilitary
groups began to proliferate let's just
say that the members of the Taunton
makuts quickly found new jobs things got
even worse when in 1995 president Jean
Bertrand aristid who had been overthrown
by the Army in 1991 and returned to
power in 1994 with the help of the
United States decided to dissolve the
armed forces and do you know what
like the former members of the Tonton
makutz many soldiers also sought new
employment in the sector they knew best
that is they joined gangs and Guerrilla
groups or created them directly these
were gangs that began to collaborate
with the various political factions in
fact president aristid himself the one
who disbanded the Army had his own
guerrillas the chimeras who were in
charge of attacking the opposition and
silencing dissidents and so it was until
2004 when he was overthrown again this
time by the gang known as the cannibal
Army along with the paramilitary group
revolutionary front for the advancement
and progress of Haiti and that visual
politic viewers is how hesi came to
resemble the board game Risk but for
gangs paramilitaries and criminal groups
they took turns imposing their own laws
and not surprisingly between power
struggles social confrontations
corruption and generalized violence we
cannot be surprised to find news stories
like this one un warns of catastrophic
levels of hunger in parts of Haiti in a
country of barely 12 million people
almost 5 million are on the verge of
starvation and more than half of them
are children in addition to this we must
add the cholera epidemic that is
sweeping the country and that is already
amassed at least 15
000 cases and left 450 dead as far as we
know the situation is critical and when
critical situations arise Desperate
Measures are taken check this out
a desperate president
as I have already said heshi's extreme
violence is not exactly new however what
I have not yet told you is that since
2021 the levels of violence and
criminality have reached levels not seen
since the duvalier dictatorship and the
question is why well basically because
of the assassination of jovenel movies
[Music]
president Luis was implicated in a
corruption Scandal related to the
embezzlement of funds from Petro Caribe
the Venezuelan sponsored project to sell
its oil in the region however his
presidency was not only marked by
corruption but also by perpetuating
himself in power without calling
elections when they were due and
remaining in office after his term ended
on the 7th of February 2021 in the end
in July of that same year he was
assassinated by a militia composed
mainly of Colombians of course the
assassination remains a mystery to this
day two of the Assassins were DEA
informants and several had been trained
by the U.S military several hypotheses
have been put forward but the most
likely held is that Luis was killed just
before publishing a list of drug
traffickers to be pursued
whatever the case the fact is that
Maurice was overthrown and has always
happens the power vacuum is quickly
filled by other players and this is
where one of the great protagonists of
this video appears Ariel Henri Hades
interim president prime minister and
minister of the interior
foreign
has had enormous opposition a
neurosurgeon and now interim president
he is tremendously unpopular a large
part of Haitians see him as an
illegitimate president and not only
because he has succeeded a presidency
whose term had already expired but also
because he has refused to hold elections
even though he promised that by the end
of 2022 there would be a date set for
those elections however he then argued
that the necessary conditions had not
been met so far from the elections being
called after all the deadlines have
expired we find ourselves with news
stories like this one Haiti left with no
elected government officials as it
spirals towards Anarchy last 10
remaining Senators leave office with
gangs controlling much of the capital A
malnutrition crisis and a cholera
outbreak in other words in addition to
the fact that Henri has refused to leave
the presidency now there are no longer
any deputies or Senators because their
terms have expired to give you an idea
even the gangs are demanding elections
but since Henry has decided to turn a
deaf ear violence has skyrocketed even
more for example in the four years
between two thousand 18 and 2022 alone
the number of homicides practically
tripled to touch the barrier of 20
homicides per 100 000 inhabitants making
Haiti one of the most dangerous
countries in the world the gangs have
taken to the streets to achieve what the
political Partners cannot at The Ballot
Box power over much of the country and
especially much of the capital port or
Prince
supported by narcotics and arms
trafficking The Gangs especially those
linked to the Coalition of gangs known
as the G9 have managed as you can see on
the map to take control of a large part
of the coast of the port or Prince Bay
the nerve center of the Haitian economy
in fact to give you an idea the G9 has
even outtaken over the country's main
oil terminal the varu terminal which
threw Haiti into total chaos since oil
is its main source of energy to put all
of this in perspective let's quickly
recap we have a country taken over by
gangs with sky-high violence rates a lot
of corruption a cholera outbreak the
lowest per capita income in the Americas
no institutions and a president who does
not want to leave power in other words
we have all the possible ingredients to
bring to Country to the brink of
collapse and that is precisely the
situation in which Haiti finds itself
and this has led President Henri to make
this decision Haitian government asks
for international military assistance
exactly visualpolitik viewers the
Haitian president himself has called for
other countries to intervene in the
country particularly the United States
but the question is who on Earth would
be willing to to carry out such an
operation that is to deploy troops to
fake gangs and drug trafficking in a
completely broken country do you really
think that that is even possible well
the truth it seems unlikely
[Music]
in fact the United States does not want
under any circumstances to have to send
troops again as it did in 1916 and 1994
achieving practically nothing except to
put another authoritarian government in
power that ended up making things even
worse so Washington ducked the issue and
passed the buck to Canada Trudeau
quickly refused though he said that
Canada would not organize such an
intervention unless there was a
unanimity among all political actors in
the country as you can imagine that is
practically impossible so the question
is what then maybe the UN well that
doesn't look likely either in fact it is
only relatively recently that the UN
ended its stabilization mission in Haiti
and apart from the fact that it is an
obvious failure to top it all off the
intervention of the blue helmets was
fraught with controversy for having
apparently provoked several rapes of
Haitian women cover mergers the
introduction of Cholera in the country
etc etc etc it is almost certain that
this time the UN will prefer to stay out
of it therefore what the United Nations
proposed is that this intervention be
carried out by a country that I'm pretty
sure many of you did not expect to see
in this story I'm talking about the
United Mexican States Mexico and why
Mexico
um
basically because the country's
experience in the fight against
organized crime and not only that it
would also alleviate the arrival of
Haitian refugees on its own Shores be
that as it may for the moment this
option is stalled something like we have
enough problems as it is thank you very
much so then is Haiti destined to be
taken over by gangs will the country end
up exploding well for the moment what we
know is that the president has taken
notice of another security strategy a
strategy that has been making headlines
in the international press I'm certain
many of you already have an idea so
let's take a look
Kelly's plan for Haiti
[Music]
indeed today we have to talk once again
about the controversial ukulele the
architect of the destruction of the
balance between security and freedom in
El Salvador but for many also the
Messiah of Peace in Latin America we
have already told you both on
visualpolitik and in our weekly patreon
bulletin about what buchelli is doing in
El Salvador but in case anyone is lost
I'll summarize it for you
[Music]
overall the Salvadoran president has
implemented an extremely heavy-handed
strategy against the gangs and crime
plaguing the country he has militarized
public security and provided better
equipment to both the military and the
police in addition in order to carry out
its drastic measures the strategy to
create a state of emergency that has
allowed it to suspend several
fundamental rights such as the
inviolability of Correspondence privacy
of communications the right to defense
and the freedom of Association a measure
that has also allowed the government to
detain gang members and suspected gang
members without the need for a warrant
it has also adopted controversial
measures such as prison sentences of up
to 15 years for graffiti alluding to
gangs the reduction of food and
confiscation of mattresses in prisons
and the imposition of sanctions on media
Outlets that publish gang messages
in other words it has blatantly ignored
the protection of individual rights and
Liberties however at the cost of less
freedom and fewer guarantees the Extreme
Measures have increased Security in the
country take a look at this
as you can see the annual homicide
figure in El Salvador has been falling
since 2016 but it is undeniable that
bukeli has achieved radically lower
numbers even though that has come at the
cost of such significant issues as legal
security the presumption of innocence
and due process and then it remains to
be seen what will happen with the big
drug traffickers but it is clear that
all of these things in places like Haiti
don't seem to matter much because they
don't really exist right now therefore
it is not surprising that bukeli's
strategy has been considered a success
and now the government is considering
trying to replicate it in the island
nation Haiti to mobilize Armed Forces
against gangs no do you think Ariel onri
would be able to do the same as bukele
in El Salvador of course in the country
right now there are hardly any freedoms
or rights to lose the gangs are
constantly exercising their violence
through rape looting murder kidnapping
extortion and the like on that front the
proposed Extreme Measures do not seem
that much of a problem but what about
Haiti's real capacities that is once it
is re-established its Army its police at
its Penitentiary capacity well visual
politic viewers the truth is that the
data in hand it seems unlikely that the
Haitian government is going to be able
to pull off a bouqueli
as you can see Haiti a country with
almost twice the population of El
Salvador has less than half the number
of police officers a miniature Army and
very little prison capacity especially
after the construction of the mega
prison in El Salvador which will be able
to hold up to 40 000 additional
Prisoners the Curious thing about all
this by the way is that between 2019 and
2021 Haiti received about 2.5 billion
dollars in international Aid which as
you can see has not been put to good use
keep in mind that Haiti is according to
Transparency International one of the 10
most corrupt countries on the entire
planet so there doesn't seem to be much
hope there either in other words Haiti's
future does not look good surely now you
understand better why this is the
poorest country in the Americas the
question is do you think that it would
be worthwhile for the United States to
try and stabilize Haiti again how can
corruption be fought in Haiti will Ariel
Henry succeed in finding the key to end
the gangs what is the best formula for
fighting violence and another question
what was your image of Haiti before this
video and finally how annoyed will my
French teacher be with my pronunciations
leave us your impressions in the
comments and let's open a respectful
debate as always don't forget the here
on visualpolitik we release new videos
every week so subscribe to this Channel
and little bell button down there so you
don't miss any of our updates if you
like this video like it so we know all
the best I hope you enjoyed the video
and I'll see you next time
[Music]